vous allez qu'on ne bouge pas comme
jingle
bien c'est l'interview dernier coup de
quatre buts à l'essai pour ça oui c'est
ça bon vous êtes prêt fadel de quoi
bâtir une interview dernier coup est
parti dernier coup dur mort de charles
trenet c'est un parents avouent souvent
dernier coup de tête [ __ ] au foot j'ai
mis à edge et marque un but
on cherche des gens qui m'arrivait
veulent prendre aux paysans suisses
allaient marquer des buts on savait
gérer là encore je cherche des buteurs
junior
quand on avait beau simplement ils
marquent contre leur camp ils ont ils
cherchent des buteurs c'est payé 300
millions un dernier coup de coeur alors
dernier coup de coeur c'est un album ne
peut dire qui bah oui julien clerc ah
oui si j'étais allé bien ça va j'aime
bien mieux voir dans ce qu'on s'en fout
d'elle on se concentre dernier coup de
poing motion au violon jamais si c'est
pas crédible quand je fais ça tu es une
patate
ouais j'ai jamais vu un dernier coup de
folie dans les coups de folie
je cherche une porsche bien j'ai acheté
une maison en menant à bien
dernier coup de foudre coup de foudre
séverine ferrer
vous le regrettez un peu sévère
non non dernier coup de fil coup de fil
j'ai demandé l'adresse de ton studio
ouais voilà voilà dernier coup de rouge
c'est un petrus 82 aulas atajevas
marange espagnol avait 13 ans elle voit
pas souvent mais quand ce des bois c'est
du bon dans les coups de sang du christ
dernier coup de bluff bon là j'ai dit
ouais j'ai bluffé aux mamans parce que
je l'invité manger un couscous le
dimanche et et je lui dis en fait j'ai
oublié j'ai jeté un coup de froid
coup de froid ici dans le studio
puisqu'il car il faut mettre de bulles
comme m'accusera qui vient aux césars
avec sa wii avec ton forfait
dernier coup de blues coup de blues
quand j'ai quitté séverine fini dernier
coup droit c'était hier
mais elle a un petit garçon maintenant